pesa tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovo video sono felice ed oggi siamo in
un video particolarissimo non è un
gameplay non è un blog è trash ma tanto
trash sono già andati in onda tutte le
puntate di social face adesso ci saranno
le repliche su sky e ho deciso ragazzi
di caricare le challenge che abbiamo fa
perché nelle puntate di social face
abbiamo fatto delle challenge e
challenge più belli più ridicole se
volete vedere le puntate intere ragazzi
andate a vedere su sky che ci sono le
repliche ed ragazzi io in questi giorni
vi farò vedere le mie challenge più
ridicole cioè quelle che ho fatto più
ridicoli in assoluto la prima challenge
di oggi era l'antico yogurt challenge
cover che ho fatto contro greta arn
challenge che consiste nel bere più
yogurt possibile ea me lo yogurt fa
veramente schifo vi lascio la challenger
ragazzi buona visione
[Musica]
la challenge di oggi si chiama in
produzione vuole chiederete ma perché
involuzione perché qua abbiamo greta e
lorenzo e noi li toglieremo il pollice
opponibile ovviamente non meno
taglieremo è no ma lo tagliamo
[Musica]
praticamente voi avrete il pollice
incollato al palmo e dovete aprire tutte
queste quattro confezioni di yogurt e
chi ne beve di più vince
[Musica]
avete tre minuti dobbiamo fare dobbiamo
mangiare e mangiare più yogurt possibile
cene quanti sono alti poco 12 3 2 1 è
che non è affatto una tattica migliore
tattica migliore
una tattica mi fa ragazzi mi fa
veramente schifo mi fa troppo schifo non
non ce la posso fare io sbocco non mi fa
schifo lo yogurt mi fa veramente schifo
lo sto per finire come dominus
per finire c'è sta mangiando comune
animali curdi battermi ci sentiamo
contro gli piace neanche lo yogurt
arrivano per di frate lorenzo guida
ne mancano tre è la finito elezioni è il
primo minuto è andato ragazzi devo farci
assolutamente non voglio fare la
penitenza è poi arrivato al traguardo
resta assai aveva definito ei ragazzi
famiglie sembra qui intanto magrolino il
tipico ragazzo secco e avete visto
quanti yogurt ha mangiato io devo aprire
nei propri ricordi decreta ma la
funzione ma l'unica cosa di cui ti devi
preoccupare che espongono i criteri non
so se presenti cosa c'è nella rotta
delle penitenze fossi in te mangia è
molto più velocemente 10 9 8 7 6 5
contro 1
infine ragazzo ha stravinto lorenzo ho
finito perché mette quasi
[Musica]
tifosissimo scusatevi però dovevamo
assolutamente vincere
mi spiace greta quindi ragazzi miei
questo è stata challenge contro greta è
stato orribile non ragazzino me lo so
spiegare quanto mi fa schifo lo io la
melody lo yogurt lo odio non lo so
perché mi fa cagare molle perché niente
ragazzi questa era la prima delle
challenge spero che i video vi sia
piaciuto per guardare le puntate qui
inter e andate a vedere su sky che ci
sono le repliche più avanti caricherò
comunque le altre challenge quindi
tenetevi pronti ragazzi miei spero che
video vi sia piaciuto e cosa i due video
più giorno sul documento è un mi piace
anche la pagina di facebook e come nei
video tofane descrizione servizi
discreti ai cibi bianco o lanciato in
tibet pro sono riuscito a riprenderlo
non so come sarà la forza e lo yogurt
beh ragazzi